[Musique]
bienvenue dans le débat sur France 24 en
Iran depuis un mois le visage de Marsa
Amini mort en détention après son
arrestation par la police des morts des
morts et toujours le symbole de la
révolte des iraniennes depuis un mois
chaque jour connaît des contestations
contre le pouvoir religieux d'abord à
sakaise en Kurdistan iranien d'où tu es
originaire Marsa Amini puis dans une
trentaine de villes du pays les
affrontements avec les forces de l'ordre
on fait au moins 100 morts des
personnalités des stars de l'étranger
expriment leurs colères sur les réseaux
sociaux l'ONU a demandé une enquête sur
la mort de Marsa mini Washington a
annoncé des sanctions économiques visant
la police des mœurs iraniennes le
président iranien Ibrahim raï ici a
accusé les États-Unis de mener une
politique de déstabilisation contre la
République islamique un mois après la
mort de Marsa Amini on va revenir sur
l'audace de ces iraniennes de ses
iraniens face à la répression du régime
cette révolte devien un tel une
révolution quelle est la réaction de la
communauté internationale le régime
iranien peut-il vaciller peut-il tomber
quels sont les scénarios possibles et
bien on va en parler avec mes invités
j'ai à côté de moi bar McCoy bonsoir bar
journaliste à France 24 franco-iranienne
et qui étudie la question depuis
justement un mois merci d'être avec nous
bah en face de vous Chala Chafik bonsoir
à vous vous êtes écrivaine sociologue
activiste vous avez pris part d'ailleurs
la révolution de 1979 avant d'être exilé
en France votre dernier livre le
rendez-vous iranien de Simone de
Beauvoir merci d'être avec nous et
bienvenue dans le débat nous avons avec
nous également Farid va être bonsoir
directeur de l'Observatoire du
Moyen-Orient de la Fondation Jean Jaurès
bienvenue à vous en face de vous David
Rigoulet rose bonsoir David rigole et
rose bienvenue à rédacteur en chef de la
revue Orient stratégique auteur de la
République islamique d'Iran en crise
systémique et c'est aux éditions
l'Harmattan ça vient de sortir dire
merci d'être là vous pouvez également
participer sur les réseaux sociaux via
le hashtag débat F24 tout au long de
l'émission alors n'hésitez pas femme vit
liberté c'est ce slogan qui est brandi
donc par la jeunesse iranienne depuis un
mois et cela malgré la répression féroce
on fait un point en images avec Cécilia
Lucio
s'il ne devait y en avoir qu'un seul ce
serait lui le visage de la contestation
iranienne celui de Marsa mini 22 ans sa
mort le 16 septembre dernier a déclenché
un vent de colère inédit dans le pays
trois jours plus tôt la jeune femme
originaire du Kurdistan est arrêtée à
Téhéran motif port de vêtements
inappropriés c'est la police des mœurs
qui l'embarque son hijab ne couvrait pas
assez ses cheveux la suite est assez
floue selon les autorités l'étudiante
serait tombée dans le coma à cause d'une
santé fragile Terrans on va même aller
jusqu'à diffuser et ses images on y voit
une jeune femme présentée comme Marsa
s'écroulait est également diffusé les
images de son supposé transfert à
l'hôpital c'est là qu'elle décédera
apparemment elle avait des antécédents
de maladies cela est indiqué dans le
rapport à l'âge de 5 ans elle a subi une
opération du cerveau
mais pour la rue il ne fait aucun doute
l'étudiant a été battu à mort la police
des mœurs s'est régulièrement critiquée
pour ses interventions violentes à
l'égard des femmes le lendemain c'est
funérailles sont organisés à sa raison
Kurdistan dans sa ville natale
c'est dans cette région que naît le
mouvement de protestation
24 heures plus tard un geste va devenir
viral un geste au combien risqué des
femmes retirent leur voile en pleine rue
elles vont même jusqu'à brûler leur et
Jack
[Applaudissements]
ce jour-là le régime iranien coupe toute
connexion à Internet mais de nombreuses
vidéos sortent quand même du pays le
mouvement s'intensifie avec les
universitaires les hommes y voit aussi
un moment Tom à saisir
regardez dans les rues ce qui proteste
aux côtés des femmes sont des hommes à
côté de chaque femme il y a un homme qui
se bat et qui a des revendications
depuis plus d'un jour ne passe sans
qu'une manifestation soit organisée le
vent de la colère remporte toutes les
villes des manifestations qui virent à
l'affrontement
les forces de l'ordre qui parfois mal
réel
de nombreux manifestants sont frappés au
fil des jours les arrestations se
multiplient le nombre de morts aussi
et des manifestations en
pro-gouvernement sont organisées
mais rien n'y fait les femmes iraniennes
continuent de défier la police des mœurs
un autre geste va marquer les esprits
elle se filme en train de se couper les
cheveux
on peut pas s'empêcher d'être un mur en
regardant ce reportage bar justement ce
qui frappe vraiment encore c'est la
jeunesse de ces iraniennes donc il y a
Marsa mini qui était 22 ans mais on
parle aussi de toutes ces lycéennes qui
sont devenus aussi des icônes avec ce
slogan femme vit liberté tout à fait
aujourd'hui des gens manifesté encore
dans une université et dans les jours
qui précédaient il y avait beaucoup
d'images qui circulaient de lycéenne qui
manifestaient soit dans leurs écoles
soit à l'extérieur et effectivement les
gens sont très très jeunes les
manifestants dans la rue dans les lycées
et il le paye aussi au prix fort là on
est en train de montrer derrière moi des
images de Nika qui est une jeune fille
qui avait 16 ans lorsqu'elle a été tuée
dans les manifestations elle n'est pas
la seule malheureusement il y a beaucoup
d'enfants qui sont décédés dans ces
manifestations je crois qu'il y a une
ONG Irène iron Human Rights qui a
dénombré 23 23 ou 28 23 enfants qui sont
décédés depuis le début de de ses
contestations
il y a des enfants aussi qui semble-t-il
sont été ont été arrêtés on est sans
nouvelles d'eux il y a des parents qui
sont sans nouvelles de leur dans leurs
enfants il est difficile d'avoir des
informations claires peut-être qu'au fil
des semaines dans les semaines qui
viennent on sera encore
qu'elle est vraiment le nombre exact de
ces victimes juvéniles de la répression
de sa manifestation n'arrête pas de
protester vous le disiez il y a encore
c'était le cas encore aujourd'hui à
l'Université de Téhéran Shella Chafik
vous avez participé à la révolution de
1979 celle qui a entraîné ensuite la
mise en place du fameux de la théocratie
iranienne vous êtes exilé en France
depuis finalement ça vous rappelle un
peu ce qui s'est passé à l'époque ou pas
ce qui se passe aujourd'hui oui
absolument ça me renvoie ma propre
jeunesse où j'étais dans la rue et donc
il y avait une jeunesse qui était dans
la rue avec le slogan de la liberté mais
en fait le pouvoir islamisme je
l'appelle le pouvoir islamiste puisque
théocratique c'est pas pour moi sont pas
très précis alors ça ils ont récupéré en
fait avec l'Alliance des autres comme
les forces de gauche et de droite à
l'époque l'opposition de chat mais qui
n'avait pas réfléchi sur le sens de la
liberté et le programme de l'autre ça
veut dire le comment en faisant de la
religion une idéologie on va être on va
mettre en place un régime liberticide
dans ce que vous venez de dire le
reportage je voudrais quand même
préciser qu'aujourd'hui hier il y a eu
des centaines de médecins qui ont écrit
une lettre à l'intérieur de l'Iran pour
protester tout ce qui a été rapporté ou
reporté par le régime sur les causes de
l'amour de Maza maintenant il y a de
protestations à l'intérieur de corps
médical contre les mensonges de l'État
donc il y a d'une part ça et c'est pas
parfois qu'il tire c'est souvent qu'il
tire sur les les manifestants et sans la
même sur les images
j'imagine que vous validez ce qui vient
d'être dit j'ai vu que les arrestations
d'ailleurs concernent essentiellement
des jeunes entre 14 et 18 ans donc la
répression est particulièrement féroce
contre cette jeunesse j'ai lu aussi que
les juges ont pour consigne de ne pas
prononcer de peine faible justement à
l'égard donc de ce qu'ils appellent les
principaux éléments des émeutes
exactement c'est le chef du pouvoir
judiciaire en Iran qui demande de ne pas
saigner des peines faibles ça se ressent
en lui une injustice envers la
Révolution et la révolutionnaire et oui
effectivement de nombreux jeunes des
adolescents ils sont très jeunes qui
manifestent qui sont les visages de ce
mouvement mais pas que nous sommes
vagues nous sommes face à une grosse
vague d'arrestation en Iran et les gens
qui sont arrêtés n'ont pas forcément
participé aux manifestations on les
arrête pour être sûr qu'ils vont pas
devenir des figures de ce mouvement donc
des personnalités qui ont
potentiellement le potentiel de devenir
des leaders sont déjà arrêtés par le
régime on voit aujourd'hui que
effectivement ça a commencé avec les
fins mais avec le voile avec les
étudiants les étudiants les lycéens mais
maintenant ça tous les secteurs on a vu
dans le sud de l'Iran l'industrie
pétrochimique on va les avocats à térans
il y a des grèves dans les raffineries
c'est un mouvement qui prend de
l'ampleur et c'est cette étape en fait
qui va être fondamentale de voir si il y
aura une réussite de mobilisation
générale de tous les secteurs du pays ou
non aujourd'hui on voit que ça avance en
tout cas le mouvement ne s'affaiblit pas
ça avance elle a répression aussi et au
même niveau devient de plus en plus
féroce la répression est extrême est-ce
qu'elle est pire qu'avant est-ce qu'elle
est liée justement au fait qu'il y a une
guerre de succession au sein du pouvoir
iranien avec cette succession possible
probable du Guide suprême justement vous
mentionnez il y a donc ce rapport
médical officiel qui est affirmé que
Marsa a mini est mort d'une tumeur
célèbre cérébrale non pas de coût donc
il se justifie de l'autre côté il
justifie leur répression oui mais on
peut se demander d'ailleurs pourquoi ils
ont ils ont cherché à donner cette
version parce que c'est ça alimente en
plus à contrario la défiance et les
réactions encore plus violentes en face
parce que c'est tellement confortable
dans ton un rapport qui est de cette
nature que on comprend pas très bien
forcément
la stratégie de ce point de vue là il y
a il y a un flottement quand même très
net c'est à dire qu'il y a une
répression féroce particulièrement dans
les périphéries du pays c'était un
Kurdistan on va revenir d'ailleurs sur
la question
il tire à l'arme lourdes donc c'est
c'est vraiment là oui c'est et vous
évoquez les les les jeunes et les
enfants beaucoup de d'enfants justement
ont été tués dans ces régions là
notamment elles Aiden ce qui a eu un
viol d'une jeune fille par un gardien de
la révolution qui manifestement à payer
de sa vie d'ailleurs son crime mais donc
il y a une féroce parce que il y a une
hantise de la part du pouvoir central
que c'est périphéries justement se
détachent et soit alimenté par les
Kurdes d'Irak par exemple ou ou les les
baluches du Pakistan donc il y a ça donc
dans ces deux zones là la répression est
encore plus sévère en plus elle venait
Marsa mini du Kurdistan donc c'était
c'est là que ça a démarré
alors ça ça rentre dans les éléments de
langage du régime de dire que sa famille
était liée au Komala c'est-à-dire un
parti
indépendante discours etc donc
effectivement une hantise d'origine ce
qui n'empêche pas une répression aussi
féroce dans les dans les villes parce
que les villes contre les jeunes parce
que ils ont très peur ils comprennent
pas ce qui se passe en fait ils
comprennent pas donc ça les dépasse
d'autant plus c'est une fuite en avant
d'autant plus que la jeunesse actuelle
alors je mettrai par rapport à 79
corrigerait si justement c'est déjà
arrivé à l'époque la jeunesse n'était
pas massivement éduquée comme
aujourd'hui vous parlez de 79 ou 2019
parce que non 79 79 en fait 30% mais il
faut pas oublier quoi à l'époque de 79
moi j'étais à l'université étudiante 30%
des gens à l'université étaient des
femmes des étudiants étaient des
étudiantes donc après aujourd'hui c'est
plus de 50% mais si vous voulez
Lolo l'actuel problème quand vous parlez
de zahidan il y a un viol encore on
arrive à la question de corps des femmes
si vous voulez il y avait un viol et de
la part d'un agent de pouvoir il se
donne la solution ici même ici même et
on compte pas ses morts par rapport à à
la Révolution générale mais ça ça fait
partie de cela ça veut dire tout ce qui
est tout ce qui se passe dans la dans le
périphérie ça rentre tout et les
problématiques se rejoint le viol avec
la question de voile obligatoire si vous
voulez c'est ça les réseaux sociaux en
tout cas on fait aussi la différence on
peut dire c'est peut-être la grande
différence avec justement 79 comment se
fait-il que le régime ne parvienne pas
parce que justement on l'a vu ils ont
d'abord effectivement essayer de couper
internet assez vite et aujourd'hui on
voit encore beaucoup d'images sur les
réseaux donc comment l'expliquer on dit
que c'est une révolution une révolte
TikTok c'est c'est bien formulé ça tous
ces tous ces jeunes qui sont qui sont
dans la rue ce sont les mêmes jeunes
qu'on a en France et la génération Z la
génération des réseaux sociaux ils sont
sur TikTok sur Instagram sur Twitter et
une des premières choses que que l'État
iranien a fait c'est de ralentir et
bloquer internet mais ils n'ont pas
coupé totalement c'est pas tout à fait
qu'il n'y arrive pas mais c'est qui
alors en 2019 il y a eu une des révoltes
en Iran et cette fois ils ont fait un
blackout d'Internet ça a duré plusieurs
jours il y a eu énormément de morts
cette fois cette année ils ont pas coupé
internet ils ont juste ralenti et ils
font des coupures ciblées par exemple
lorsqu'il y a eu des répressions à
l'université Sharif ils ont coupé juste
sur place cette nuit là et les coupures
ont lieu en fin de journée la nuit pour
éviter que les gens utilisent les
réseaux sociaux pour se rassembler mais
ensuite le matin il est possible d'avoir
plus facilement déconnexions donc ils
ont pas coupé totalement besoin pour
l'économie en fait il utilise lui-même
par rapport économiques en 2009 même si
ils sont coupés Internet d'une part et
d'autre part ces jeunes qui connaissent
bien les réseaux sociaux connaissent
aussi tout à fait savent tout à fait
comment on utilise un VPN et tout un tas
de logiciels d'applications qui servent
à se connecter à Internet malgré tout
quoi qu'il arrive ils peuvent contourner
une censure qui est donc moins
importante vous le dites que en 2019 on
va regarder quand même les hackers parce
que les hackers ils ont fait un coup si
on peut dire en tout cas ils ont hacké
une émission de télévision en prime time
on a vu vraiment ces images sur les
réseaux justement et ça a fait grand
bruit Farid est-ce que Farid va est-ce
que effectivement c'est hacker font
partie de ces
contestataires de cette contestation ah
oui tout à fait depuis le début du
mouvement on va aller à Kerk qui attaque
les différents sites du gouvernement
iranien et voir cette image est
fortement symbolique le Grand Journal
iranien est quand même très symbolique
très fermé par par le système donc oui
d'ailleurs c'est des hacker mais aussi
très probablement des gens qui sont sur
place et qui travaillent à
l'organisation télé radio de la ce qui
serait très problématique pour eux parce
que c'est un organisation très très
sécuritaire pour revenir sur les images
il faut comprendre qu'effectivement le
régime un savoir-faire en matière de de
supprimer les images de censure mais les
Iraniens aussi ils ont pu créer un
savoir-faire en matière de pour
détourner cette censure et il y a aussi
une solidarité
entre ceux qui connaissent le système
exactement on sent les deux et il y a
des VPN les ironiens ils ont grandi avec
ça ils ont tous grandi avec ça mais
malgré tout il regarde les séries
Netflix donc voilà ils ont vécu tout ça
et aujourd'hui ce qui est important
c'est de comprendre aussi la solidarité
de la diasporer en ligne qui est énorme
en Occident avec les Iraniens de
l'intérieur pour relayer les images pour
médiatiser tout ça donc voilà c'est on
est face
il est pas coup quand il est pas coupé
il envoie les films et les télés ici le
relâche on va revenir d'ailleurs sur
cette solidarité internationale David
rigolo encore un dernier mot sur ce
mouvement il n'y a pas de leader est-ce
que c'est ça un peu je dirais la
faiblesse du mouvement pour que ça
puisse aller plus loin
ça reste sporadique ça va spontané oui
mais c'est effectivement la génération Z
c'est elle c'est la génération connectée
Internet et donc c'est à la fois la
force et la faiblesse de cette dynamique
c'est la force parce que c'est très
difficile pour les autorités
d'identifier des leaders des têtes qui
pourraient être coupées donc parce que
c'est des centralisé et c'est aussi la
faiblesse parce qu'il y a un moment se
posera la question d'une potentielle
alternative politique qui doit être
incarnée par des leaders et évidemment
le régime joue là-dessus en comptant sur
le fait que finalement il sera en mesure
de maîtriser cette absence de
d'expression politique puisqu'il y a
toujours parié sur le fait qu'il y
aurait pas d'alternative politique au
lui-même jouait là-dessus là aussi que
c'est différent de 1970
pas laissé la tête ils n'ont pas ils ont
coupé toutes les têtes dès le début ça
veut dire en fait la République
islamique la terreur et pas un outil
c'est un pilier de système ils ont
laissé aucune tête que ce soit à
l'extérieur ils ont ils ont tué les
opposants qui pouvaient être alternative
à l'intérieur ils sont en prison ils ont
été tués
de femmes qui sont mortes en fait voilà
ils sont ils sont mais moi je compte
aussi sur le fait si vous voulez quand
vous voyez un mouvement dans son dans
son avancées pour rééventuellement pour
éventuellement
créer les nouvelles formes
d'organisation j'espère mais en tout cas
comme vous je suis d'accord sur le fait
que ça pourrait être un une faiblesse
mais ça pourrait être aussi une force
puisque ils peuvent pas couper les têtes
une force vous pensez je suis tout à
fait d'accord il faut pas croire que les
jeunes aujourd'hui en Iran cherche
forcément à leader je veux dire en 70
ans
ça n'a pas forcément donné une bonne
chose en 2009 il y avait
dès qu'il a été enfermé chez lui il y
avait plus de mouvement donc faut pas
croire aujourd'hui que que les jeunes
ils font plus confiance et ils veulent
pas forcément avoir un leader après
effectivement dans la deuxième phase du
mouvement un jour pour l'alternance
politique qui sera nécessaire mais je
suis sûr qu'à un moment il y aura un
leadership interne en Iran qui qui va
surgir les manifestations de soutien en
tout cas vous en parliez au mouvement
ont lieu dans un un peu partout en
Europe au Canada aussi à des
manifestations de soutien on a vu aussi
des artistes des politiques qui ont
manifesté leur solidarité les États-Unis
ont réimposé des sanctions sévères à
Téhéran vous le savez qui leur retrait
unilatérale de l'accord sur le nucléaire
on fait un point avec Julia guenaille
mais on en parle ensuite
des femmes qui brûlent leur voile en
soutient aux iraniennes les scènes comme
celle-ci se sont multipliées dans le
monde ces derniers mois ici en Syrie des
activistes Kurdes justice pour Marseille
à minuit la jeune femme originaire du
Kurdistan iranien tué par la police il y
a maintenant un mois après une
arrestation pour un voile mal porté
un soutien qui sait aussi rendu visible
sur les réseaux sociaux ou la vidéo de
cette femme chantant le chant
révolutionnaire italien bella ciao en
farci a été vu des millions de fois
et qui Miguel
mais également avec ses vidéos ou des
femmes parmi les plus grandes actrices
et chanteuses françaises se coupent les
cheveux un geste repris par des femmes
politiques comme la mère de Paris devant
l'hôtel de ville ou un corps par 7 euros
députés suédoise devant l'hémicycle
ouais même life freedom depuis un mois
les manifestations se multiplient le
week-end dernier des dizaines de
milliers de personnes ont manifesté dans
150 villes aux quatre coins du monde
partout en même slogan celui qui fait
des rizières à
femme liberté ici à Paris
la caboule en avait gagné
au Royaume-Uni ennemis historique de
l'Iran Israël a également montré son
soutien aux manifestant en illuminant
l'hôtel de ville de Tel-Aviv avec le
slogan symbolique et au-delà des
symboles le Canada et les États-Unis ont
pris des sanctions économiques contre
l'Iran l'Union européenne elle aussi
indiquée examinée des mesures
restrictives bah vous avez l'impression
que quand même une mobilisation de la
communauté internationale
ça commence à se réveiller notamment en
France il y a des manuel Macron a fait
des déclarations hier de soutien on va
l'écouter justement un peu plus tard
et il est question de sanctions un petit
peu l'Union européenne notamment est en
train de discuter des sanctions et par
ailleurs elle en avait déjà mis en place
des sanctions en fait on en entendait
assez peu parler mais par exemple en
Iran les équipements pouvant être
utilisés pour surveiller ou intercepter
l'Internet et les communications
téléphoniques sur les réseaux mobiles
sont sanctionnés par l'Union l'Union
européenne c'est à dire on interdit
l'importation en Iran de ce de ce type
d'équipement donc à cela peut-être vont
s'ajouter de nouvelles chansons qui vont
ils souhaitent cibler les responsables
des répressions d'après ce que ce que
j'ai compris donc on attend discussion
ça commence à ça commence à bouger de ce
point de vue là mais les les différents
dirigeants des différents pays sont tout
de même gênés c'est-à-dire ils ont peur
aussi d'en faire trop
et du coup que ce soit contre-productif
car on les accuse en Iran d'être d'être
à l'origine de ces troubles et de
fomenter ces troubles donc ils ont aussi
une crainte d'alimenter ce discours vous
êtes d'accord est-ce qu'il faudrait plus
de sanctions justement à la fois côté
européen côté américain donc là je pense
que l'Occident n'a pas trouvé des
mesures assez sérieuses par rapport à
par rapport à ce régime si vous voulez
c'est ce qui est ces sanctions regardez
les sanctions américaines les Iraniens
les protestent que pourquoi parce que
c'est inefficace et c'est ça donne rien
les agents ils ont ils ont ils ont un ça
veut dire en fait il y a une liste
agents de répression tout d'abord c'est
énorme après ils vont jamais venir en
Occident ça veut dire quoi ils vont être
mais vous savez ils ont fait déjà à
l'époque il y a ils ont fait ça et ça a
coûté plus pour les Iraniens dans nos
familles qui voulaient un visa ils ont
pas eu mais alors que les agents de la
République islamique sont partout ils
ont tué les opposants tranquille moi je
trouve que c'est des mesures ça
fonctionne pas si vous voulez cosmétique
l'Europe c'est sur les mesures
cosmétiques ça veut dire il faut
vraiment qu'il y ait une
sérieuse condamnation de cette
répression quand il y ait le niveau
diplomatique au niveau diplomatique
qu'il y ait des commandes de ce soit
plus
finalement l'Iran on a l'impression que
c'est un des pays les plus isolés de la
planète c'est peut-être pas le cas
finalement
en tout cas sur cette question des
sanctions c'est une question très
délicate pour les puissances
occidentales aussi il faut pas oublier
le dossier nucléaire iranien alors
justement la Maison Blanche dit
aujourd'hui que il y a aucune chance
qu'il soit qu'il soit bouclée
nucléaire ils ont reçu beaucoup donc à
un moment donné si c'est pas la
cornucléaire de 2015 il doit réfléchir
un plan B aujourd'hui on a du mal à
imaginer quel serait ce plan B donc
c'est une réelle question mais on a
aussi du mal à imaginer les puissances
occidentales signer un accord avec ici
donc c'est vraiment un digmatique pour
aller plus en s'occidentales ce qu'il
faut faire et concernant les sanctions
d'accord j'ai entendu les annonces
sanctions mais ils sont déjà sanctionnés
pour faire vaciller le régime ces
sanctions ça peut faire mal ça ça réduit
le budget militaire de l'Iran leurs
activités régionales mais oui
effectivement ça n'a pas donné ce qu'on
voulait donc oui effectivement il faut
prendre des mesures ciblées je veux dire
c'est quand même un 16 par intéressant
c'est triste de voir que les enfants des
agents du régime comme vous dites sont
peuvent venir tranquillement profiter de
la liberté en Europe et que des
militants des militantes ou des
intellectuels des problèmes pour avoir
des visas mais comment expliquer ça
bah question la dernière marche pour les
visas aussi les conditions financières
c'est aussi voilà c'est c'est pas
évident de faire ces démarches on peut
faire des choses il y a des choses à
faire vous pensez
à cette question de nucléaire
effectivement cet accord dans
Donald Trump avait sortir les États-Unis
effectivement Joe Biden a essayé de
renégocier les Européens aussi sont
partis prenantes bref manifestement pour
l'instant on est dans l'impasse donc ça
veut dire que l'Iran est toujours très
isolé elle a aussi une capacité
d'influence importante régionale oui
mais bon qui est depuis plusieurs années
mais qui a connu quand même un coup
d'arrêt assez significatif au moment de
la
les l'exécution enfin l'élimination de
la sème solemani ça a donné un coup
d'arrêt et on voit d'ailleurs dans le
cas d'Irak puisque un des généraux oui
c'était le chef de la force côte donc
les bras armés extérieurs des Gardiens
de la révolution qui avait qui était un
stratège donc un cahier planifié
régionale de l'Iran la décennie
précédente et c'est vrai que les
Américains
et ça un peu déstabilisé quand même
justement le la planification de de
cette influence on l'a vu en Irak
d'ailleurs avec c'est pas hasard si
mocta des Sader c'est agité etc donc il
y a des interrogations et puis il y a un
manque de moyens quand même parce que
les sanctions pèsent sur la mobilisation
de fond clairement alors là ça valide
j'allais dire le mobile de Trump même si
c'est pas ça qui fera changer les choses
fondamentalement ça sera c'est un
arrière-plan économique d'une
cocotte-minute en réalité aujourd'hui
l'Iran c'est une cocotte-minute parce
que ça ça a sauté non pas sur une
question économique mais sur la question
du diable c'est par hasard c'est une que
si on sociétale qui renvoie à la
structure même du régime et qui
évidemment emmagasine en arrière-plan
toutes les frustrations économiques de
ces dernières décennies bien sûr mais
c'est pas le déclencheur c'est pas
forcément les sanctions elles-mêmes mais
justement on voit que on parle des
drones iraniens dans ce conflit
ukrainien donc ils exportent
effectivement des des drones aux Russes
les Iraniens d'ailleurs c'est une grande
tristesse de voir
l'état iraniens parce que c'est quand
même l'été indien qui envoie des des
armes et des drones à la Russie pour
agresser un pays indépendant l'Ukraine
mais après faut nuancer ces dons ne sont
pas très efficaces selon des rapports
britanniques et il y a aucun avantage
financier pour l'Iran à le faire c'est
juste dans une logique et de ce qu'ils
appellent leur philosophie du regard
vers l'est donc une alliance stratégique
militaire avec la Russie une alliance
économique avec la Chine qui fonctionne
pas qui fonctionne pas déjà les erreurs
n'en veulent pas les études aériennes ne
vont pas continuer leurs études en Chine
et aux États-Unis et de deux cette
alliance ne rapporte rien économiquement
alliant donc c'est plus idéologique que
pragmatique c'est intéressant que vous
disiez vous disiez que les étudiants
iraniens vont étudier aux États-Unis
parce que pour Ibrahim raïti les
États-Unis c'est vraiment le grand
ennemi on va l'écouter justement on va
l'écouter il s'était entretenu enfin il
a il avait parlé aujourd'hui me
semble-t-il enfin en tout cas on va
l'écouter et puis on va écouter
également Emmanuel Macron puisqu'on en
parlait
mais là
l'option militaire américaine et
infliger une défaite humiliante à la
politique de sanctions et de pression
maximale
suite à l'échec de l'option militaire et
des sanctions américaines
Washington et ses alliés ont recours à
une politique de déstabilisation vouée à
l'échec de manière très claire la France
condamne les répressions aujourd'hui
menées par le régime iranien et nous
tenons aux côtés de ces femmes Cédric ça
ne me fait pas plaisir vous voyez sur la
photo quand je vois le président iranien
mais qu'est-ce que c'est que la
diplomatie c'est accepté de parler avec
des gens qui ne partagent pas vos
valeurs qui ne partagent pas vos
principes avec lesquels vous n'êtes pas
d'accord
ça
veut dire que on ne fait pas le destin
des peuples à leur place
et qu'aujourd'hui ce qui se passe en
Iran il faut le défendre le dire le
soutenir nous ne pouvons pas nous y
substituer donc il défend effectivement
la population mais en même temps il
parle et il le dit au président iranien
Bard donc c'est quand même la diplomatie
reste la diplomatie l'arrêt politique
Emmanuel Macron aussi gêné faut le
rappeler parce qu'il y a des il y a 5 il
me semble
français qui sont retenus en Iran en
Iran donc effectivement il marche il
marche sur des œufs
mais il affirme quand même clairement
son soutien aux manifestants j'imagine
qu'il peut pas tout dire de fait de
façon de façon publique mais que en
sous-main la France doit être
certainement en train de négocier avec
les autorités iraniennes pour pour
libérer ces otages ce discours justement
vous trouvez qu'il a qu'il a un peu
changé enfin il reste un peu ambigu
enfin en tout cas la diplomatie reste la
diplomatie oui par exemple les accords
avec le président mais après faut voir
le résultat d'accord la France a choisi
de parler avec
errant avec le président Haïti
à New York
parce que c'était un acte ça a choqué en
Iran cette poignée de main faut voir ce
qu'on a obtenu rien et ce qu'on a eu une
solution pour le nucléaire non donc on a
du mal un peu à comprendre la nécessité
de cette réunion après oui c'est pas la
France de faire la révolution des
Iraniens mais on peut prendre des
mesures encore une fois c'est bleu pour
soutenir le mouvement est-ce que sur
cette justement c'est négociations
autour du nucléaire Emmanuel Macron qui
justifie le fait que on va avoir ici
pour négocier
c'était l'objet de sa rencontre à l'ONU
c'est pas de gaieté de coeur qu'il a été
amené à poser avec le président iranien
c'est qu'effectivement il y avait c'est
un peu l'idée d'une tentative
ultime sur le nucléaire donc c'était ça
le fond des discussions parce que il
savait que le mouvement commençait et
que le finalement la finalisation d'un
accord pourrait pas se faire si c'était
vraiment la dernière il a tenté quelque
chose bon et il a il a sûrement pris axe
du fait que aujourd'hui l'accord
qu'il ait été envisagé et et caduque
c'est-à-dire qu'il sera pas finalisé et
tout le monde pense à un plan B
justement puisque vous évoquez un plan B
ça veut dire négociation toujours quand
même c'est justement quoi après
l'annonce finalisation de la corde et du
côté américain c'est déjà intégré c'est
à dire qu'il y aura pas d'accord et on
réfléchit à comment gérer la situation
d'un en accord
est-ce que ça a été si mal interprété en
Iran justement cette image d'Emmanuel
Macron et de racisme parce que depuis
longtemps ça veut dire je reviens je
reviens ça veut dire il y a une
historique à ces relations de l'Iran
avec les pays européens et l'Amérique
donc il s'est l'exportation de la de
leur idéologie aussi la guerre de toute
façon c'est comme ça en fait l'Iran le
régime le régime ça me fait du mal de
dire le régime d'Iran c'est la
République islamique c'est le pouvoir
islamiste à dit clairement nous avons le
pouvoir en cinq capitaux la capitale du
monde Irak ça veut dire il nomme l'Irak
il nomme Liban avec ce bola ils nous Man
et il eux au même est aussi la Syrie et
il rend à jouer un rôle néfaste en série
donc les Iraniens ont encaissé tout ça
si vous voulez de tout le temps depuis
le Mouvement Vert jusqu'au maintenant
ils ont demandé au pays américain en
Amérique à l'Amérique et
européenne d'être plus ferme ça n'a pas
été fait aujourd'hui il ne supporte plus
que quand il y a les gens qui sont tués
dans la rue qu'il y ait de ces gestes
normalisants c'est pas la question de
diplomatie si vous voulez on peut faire
la diplomatie autrement que les droits
humains et la liberté des femmes soit
passe-partie sérieusement de la
diplomatie ça s'appelle une diplomatie
démocratique c'est ça que les Iraniens
veulent ils veulent aussi démocratie ils
veulent pas ils veulent pas que la
France intervient en Iran ils veulent
pas que l'Amérique intervient en Iran il
vole une diplomatie démocratique qui
tient sa parole qui tient ces valeurs
démocratiques et ça on le voit pas vous
êtes d'accord Farid
la diplomatie se concernante de ces
nucléaires on comprend mais on savait
déjà que le conservateur iranien c'était
pas avec cette réunions qu'ils allaient
retourner à l'accord et ils ont
d'ailleurs ils ont plein de raisons de
ne pas retourner à l'accord à la course
selon le rideau logique donc oui je
pense que c'était pas du pas du tout la
meilleure chose à faire aujourd'hui il
faut envoyer des signaux aux femmes
iraniennes à la jeunesse iranienne pour
leur dire qu'on comprend qu'on entend
autre message alors justement ces cinq
Français qui sont détenus en Iran ça a
été confirmé par Catherine Colonna à la
chef de la diplomatie française bar
est-ce que ça veut dire que c'est une
sorte de ils peuvent être une monnaie
d'échange pour justement le pouvoir
iranien
c'est tout à fait possible par le par le
passé ça a été le cas des otages qui ont
été échangés contre des prisonniers
iraniens en France ou dans d'autres pays
dans d'autres pays
donc il faut attendre de voir
effectivement il y a peut-être des
négociations qui qui sont en cours je
voulais ajouter aussi sur ce que sur ce
que vous venez de dire avant que j'étais
en contact avec des iraniennes qui me
qui me faisait part de leur désarroi par
rapport aux réactions internationales
elles se comparer aux afghan les
aériennes suivent de près aussi ce qui
s'est passé en Afghanistan et elle me
disait littéralement on se sent
abandonné on va être abandonné
donc abandonnés on va être abandonné
comme les Afghans au mains des taliboles
ce qui s'est passé en Afghanistan a un
retentissement
en Iran pour les Iraniennes je pense
aussi un choc un choc où ils ont été
choqué parce qu'il s'est passé dans le
pays voisin et voilà c'est c'est une
idée qui circule en tout cas
effectivement comment faire de la
diplomatie en même temps soutenir le
mouvement
c'est
d'autant plus compliqué que on veut pas
avec enfin valider le les éléments de
langage du régime qui consiste à dire
que tout ce qui se passe en Iran et
finalement le résultat d'une ingérence
extérieure puisque c'est ce qu'ils
arrêtent pas de dire que ça soit le
Guide Suprême ou le président racisme
c'est-à-dire que toutes ces émeutes sont
fomentées justement par une main
étrangère et de ce point de vue là
l'affichage des des Français et
significatives c'est de dire que
justement le l'agitation de du public et
studiant scolaire
coïncide avec la présence de ces de
Français qui étaient venus certes pour
faire du tourisme mais qui avait des
responsabilités dans les syndicats
enseignants en France qu'ils auraient
pris des contacts avec les syndicats
enseignants
à l'époque où il y avait des grèves
justement en Iran de d'enseignants très
importantes et des arrestations une
quarantaine d'arrestations donc ça le
problème de l'extérieur c'est qu'on veut
pas non plus donner l'impression que de
donner raison en fait
à la présentation
justement du régime qui qui n'a de cesse
de considérer que dans la théorie
complotiste
ce serait moi je pense que la politique
occidentale jusqu'au matin c'était de
alimenter cette ce discours idéologique
si vous voulez c'est vraiment je
comprends pas qui
accepterait que les jeunes lycéens vont
donner leur vie pour la politique
française ou pour la politique et
américaine c'est très clair que le
régime iranien trouve puisque les
syndicalisme français qui sont allés en
Iran c'est normal si vous voulez dans
tous les pays du monde quand il y a des
grèves les gens viennent de l'Ayur pour
le soutenir le régime iranien soutient
lesbola de Liban avec des millions en
voie de l'argent soutient les mouvements
idéologiques à l'extérieur personne
n'agit alors qu'au syndicalistes qui
vont là-bas bien sûr qu'ils vont prendre
la Libye pour dire mais pourquoi nous il
faut accepter pourquoi il faut même dire
non c'est absurde c'est absurde leur
argument ça absurde alors justement ce
pouvoir est-ce qu'il est fragile est-ce
qu'il est en train de vaciller est-ce
qu'il peut tomber par il est à la fois
fragilisé tout à fait parce qu'il se
passe et en même temps la machine
répressive de l'État iranien elle est
rodée depuis des années elle est en
place on voit qu'elle fait son effet il
tire quand ils ont besoin ils arrêtent
ils font faire des abeilles forcés donc
à la fois on a l'impression que ce
pouvoir il est bien en place et il veut
y rester et il a les moyens pour le
faire au niveau sécuritaire et
judiciaire et en même temps il est
fragilisé parce que ça fait un mois que
ça dure et les gens continuent de
manifester alors peut-être qu'ils sont
pas des millions dans la rue mais il y a
plein d'actes de rébellions de
désobéissance civile et tous les jours
et ça continue ça continue ça peut durer
encore longtemps est-ce que est-ce que
est-ce que ça peut faire est-ce qu'il
est fragilisé effectivement ce pouvoir
à cause des en raison des symboles aussi
en 2009 finalement on entendait souvent
des conservateurs dire oui mais c'était
une dispute interne aujourd'hui ils
peuvent pas dire ça et les gens disent
morrodictateurs ils brûle le voile
qu'elle symbole de l'islam politique
donc le symbole de la République
islamique ils sont très fragilisés quand
il y a des célébrités des intellectuels
qui invitent clairement un changement
donc oui effectivement l'État est très
structuré c'est un état très sécurité
mais une finesse je pense que le peuple
iranien est plus puissant que l'État
sécurité
pour être déjà se transformer en régime
militaire avec une prise de pouvoir des
Gardiens de la révolution qui eux
tiennent le pays enfin en tout cas
l'économie du pays il est déjà
partiellement militarisé d'ailleurs ce
qui est significatif c'est de voir le
Guide suprême qui a fait un déplacement
entouré des justement des des de chefs
militaires alors que traditionnellement
il était entouré de demande du clergé
etc donc en même temps c'est embêtant
pour lui parce que ça veut dire qu'il y
a une forme de vassalisation latente qui
le met un peu à la merci de ces
structures militariste militarisée que
sont les les Gardiens de la révolution
qui ont un rôle effectivement très
important maintenant dans l'économie
mais pas seulement et d'ailleurs à
l'époque il y avait eu ces ironique
parce que le
remélie avait dit justement qu'il
fallait pas du tout laisser la
possibilité à l'armée de s'ingérer dans
les affaires de la du gouverne de
gouvernement du pays alors c'est ce qui
se passe aujourd'hui clairement même si
il y a quand même des interrogations sur
la solidité parce que il y a un
épuisement des forces de répression au
bout d'un mois ce que vous disiez c'est
vraiment on ressent ça épuisement parce
qu'on a l'impression que vous disiez il
sortent les armes lourdes parce que
parce que c'est l'étape au-dessus et
puis et puis il y a des fissures
manifestement alors d'abord il y a entre
l'artèche l'armée traditionnelle et puis
les passes d'Aran et même au sein des
passes d'Aran il y a des interrogations
il y a des fissures parce que certains
commence à se dire que
la situation peut peut dégénérer et qui
maîtriseront pas forcément toutes les
variables de la situation donc il y a un
gros point d'interrogation mais même
l'instrument répressif
probablement connaît des doutes vous
êtes d'accord il y a aussi cette
succession cette guerre de succession de
Ali ramène qui est donc le guide suprême
qui est lui à tout j'ai vraiment un
pouvoir son fils je ne sais pas si elles
sont confirmées peut-être pourrez-vous
le faire de policiers qui auraient
effectivement basculé
au moment de voilà il y a des films tout
à fait moi je vais dans le monde
mais je pense que vous savez ce scénario
que le pasteur prendront le pouvoir ils
ont déjà le pouvoir
c'est déjà fait ils sont dans l'économie
ils ont la malmise sur tous les contrats
etc ils sont à côté comme a été dit ils
sont quand même avec le leader suprême
le fils de leader suprême qui a été déjà
désigné va être avec ça rentre donc
c'est un scénario qui nous tient pas ça
veut dire en fait c'est un de scénario
qui va faire peur au peuple nous le
peuple iranien maintenant a à encaisser
toutes les étapes depuis les choses tout
à fait passives pas si vis pacifices
pardon jusqu'au jour aujourd'hui et moi
je pense que cette il y a quelque chose
il y a une page qui est tournée deux
murs sont tombés et dans cette inédit le
mur de mensonge qui est sur lequel ils
ont établi leur pouvoir et le mur de la
peur la peur a changé de camp ça c'est
une victoire maintenant qu'est-ce qui va
se passer je peux pas dire et justement
Farid Vaide pour conclure est-ce que
effectivement c'est fissures ça pourrait
passer par des vrais fissures au sein du
système répressif ou est-ce que ça
serait cette concurrence entre le
gardien de la Révolution et le guide
enfin qu'est-ce qui parce que c'est pas
la rue qui va est-ce que la rue pourrait
vraiment
mettre fin à ce pouvoir
on voit déjà certaines personnalités
conser ça en Iran qui commence tout en
respectant les lignes rouges du régime
évidemment mais de se poser des
questions effectivement le rôle de
l'armée régulière essentielle des
gardiens aussi il faut pas oublier que
le service militaire obligatoire en Iran
donc beaucoup des soldats sont juste des
jeunes hommes c'est justement ces
dernières révolution ils soutiennent la
structure de la terrasse parce que c'est
idéologique parce que il y a des
intérêts financiers mais faut pas croire
que en tout cas l'armée régulière qui
sont tous prêts à tuer des manifestants
et des jeunes filles dans la rue après
faudra voir aussi la question de la
succession qui est fondamentale on dit
pas qui
disparaître dans deux trois ans pour un
ayatollah 84 ans et c'est dans les
standards et il a peut-être encore 10
ans on sait pas on peut pas prédire mais
c'est sûr on dit tout le temps que
l'opposition n'a pas de leadership et
ben eux aussi sans lui ils n'ont pas de
leadership aucune tête qui pourra avoir
le même on va dire charisme pour unir
toutes les tous les conservateurs
il était président de la République
depuis déjà 8 ans
par exemple quand effectivement il
décèdera ramener ça aussi ça sera une
sorte de France
élections et pas de candidats réformiste
mais force cette constater grâce ici n'a
pas le niveau il part très mal il a
aucun carré mais il a pas de vision
politique même pour les conservateurs
merci en tout cas à tous les cas d'avoir
été là on sent que effectivement la
répression va continuer mais que les
manifestations vont également continuer
en Iran ça fait un an on le disait au
début de cette émission qu'elles ont
démarré après la mort de Marsa à mini
merci Farid vaïd merci David Rigoulet
rose merci beaucoup Sheila Chafik
d'avoir été avec nous merci
de rédaction de France 24 merci à vous
tous nous avoir suivi vous restez avec
nous sur France 24